hey everybody welcome back i'm monica
jackson and it is time for
mondays with monica this week i'm
talking to an award-winning producer
musician and songwriter who's using his
talents
to help young children before we talk to
him though
i want you to hear this group that this
man
put together take a listen somewhere
[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
oh my gosh sounds like an angel right
ladies and gentlemen this group is
called pisento and this is the man right
here
his name is khan fulham he put them all
together and without further ado i want
to welcome him and khan
i want you to tell our las vegas
audience all about this group and how it
all came together merry christmas to you
by the way
merry christmas to you and thanks so
much for having me this is a
thrill um so how it all came together
about 15 years ago
i was having lunch with a good friend of
mine who became the executive
director of capitalities here in
portland and catholic charities has
served the number one
organization dealing with newer rivals
both refugees and immigrants
we started talking about the kinds of
things and the difficulties of
challenges that they face
and very clearly the first thing that
happens when you come to a new country
is you lose your voice
literally aren't you coming in speaking
french or
arabic or swahili or whatever it may be
um and that's a massive challenge to
sort of navigate
so i figured aha one thing you know
music being a universal language
if i can put all of these if i put a
group of girls together
and teach them english songs it would be
sort of a portal
into the language um and that started 15
years ago and 15 years later
over 350 girls have come through the
chorus um
100 percent of them graduated from high
school 85
have gone on to post secondary so we're
doing something right
let me tell you something when i heard
about the story and you know you and i
have talked before i absolutely love
what you're doing
bringing all these girls together and
some of their stories are horrific
ladies and gentlemen and we're not going
to get khan into those stories because
these girls are refugees and they have
come from war
war-torn countries and some of their
stories are horrific but they have
triumphed and during the holiday season
they do so many wonderful things khan
tell our viewers here at eight news now
where these girls have performed because
it's a pretty
impressive list that you guys have
yeah we performed at the united nations
several times
uh actually just before kobe hit we were
performing at the u-win with bono
wow we performed at the white house we
performed at the kennedy center we
performed at the national cathedral
and over the course of time probably
well over 300 000 people have seen the
forest live and
millions via the today show voice of
america
national public radio yeah al jazeera
and
it goes on it goes on and on and i love
that hey how are you guys funded because
i know there's always a need with the
girls coming in from all over the world
constantly you have to keep
up funding somehow so how do you do that
um we beg steel and borrow we're a very
small organization with big heart
so um every every penny counts um we do
get some grants
uh we when we perform we generally do it
for honorariums
yeah as many places we perform
particular schools
just don't have the funding for us so um
we we get it anywhere we can literally
all right hey i gotta wrap it up here
but tell everybody how they can get in
contact with you because we have a
beautiful venue here in las vegas called
the smith center and i know the ceo over
there i'd love to get you guys here so
how do we contact you how do we help you
out with funding as well
well you can just go online to
pcintu.org
and you'll see all about the course
you'll see a little button you can push
to
make a contribution and everything and
anything would be immensely
appreciated and we are so very grateful
for the opportunity
to be with us this morning hey i'm
grateful to have you my friend and we
will talk again hopefully we can get you
here at the smith center
khan fulham thank you so much and tell
all the girls at picento i send love
from las vegas
i certainly will all right take care cod
again merry christmas to you
and folks hey i am so happy to report to
you that
the moj show you know i have a facebook
live show that happens
monday through friday at 7 00 p.m we
have our charity our holiday campaign
that launches called dimes for dinners
right there on your screen we started
last week
and our charity of choice this year is
three square and drum roll please
you know i'm doing my own thing here
we have served through three square
almost 1500 free meals
yes i am so excited about that so folks
here's what you can do to get involved
all you have to do is go to my facebook
page mojo
follow me tell all your friends to
follow so for every two new followers
we give three square you give three
square a free meal for someone here in
the las vegas valley who is in need so
keep following keep telling all your
friends it's called dimes for dinners
you can hashtag it and all that kind of
fancy stuff
as well i will be checking you out and
hopefully you'll be checking me out
tonight at 7 pm
that's it for this segment of mondays
with monica